[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild hallo und willkommen zu einer neuen
Folge von Tatort Deutschland ich bin
Mirko Kasimir und ich bin Tony haer hi
zusammen Tony bei unserem heutigen Fall
kommt man aus dem Kopfschüttel nicht
raus ich wiederum bin absolut erstaunt
dass dieser Typ ernsthaft auch noch
Liebesbriefe in den Knast bekommt
aber jetzt ist erstmal Zeit dass wir ihn
vorstellen MKO die zemis Geschichte
beginnt im Zweiten Weltkrieg seine
Mutter hat eine leidenschaftliche Affäre
während ihr Mann seit seiner Einberufung
an der Front dient sie wird mit Dieter
schwanger sein leiblicher Vater soll ein
polnischer Zwangsarbeiter gewesen sein
als ihr Mann begreift dass das Kind
nicht von ihm ist gibt er den kleinen
Jungen in Bochum zur Adoption frei di
wächst in Bergen bei seinen
Adoptiveltern Ferdinand und Wilhelmine
zurweme auf odtbergen ist ein Stadtteil
von Höxter im Weserbergland also in der
recht malerischen Grenzregion von NRW
und Niedersachsen sein Adoptivvater ist
laut archiveinträgen oberzugführer also
bei der Reichsbahn wir finden ihn aber
auch als
Bankangestellten vielleicht hat er
einfach im Laufe der Jahre den Job
gewechselt die Mutter ist Hausfrau als
zurweme von einem Lehrer erfährt dass er
ein Adoptivkind ist da reißt er aus er
will seine leiblichen Eltern finden
natürlich wird er irgendwann aufgelesen
und muss zurück in den Akten heißt es
später der kleine Dieter sei in der
Folgezeit mit Zuckerbrot und Peitsche
erzogen worden der Junge wird offenbar
schnell aggressiv seine Eltern fühlen
sich schließlich überfordert und
übergeben Dieter eine
Erziehungseinrichtung dort büchst er
regelmäßig aus und wird wieder und
wieder geschnappt als Jugendlicher
beweist er gern seinen Mut indem er z.B
auf fahrende Züge aufspringt wenn ich
mir die Erziehung der 50er Jahre
vorstelle dazu überforderte Eltern und
dann den Begriff Zuckerbrot und Peitsche
furchtbar später wurde in den Prozessen
ja auch deutlich dass es regelmäßig
Schläge gab für den klein Dieter und
Stubenarrest dass die Eltern überstreng
waren da kann einfach nichts Gutes bei
rauskommen W bei diet zwe trifft es
leider zu im Alter von 12 lockte ein
15jähriges Mädchen in einen Wald stellt
ihm ein Bein schlägt dem Kind mit der
Faust auf den Kopf und fordert Geld noch
im selben Jahr schlägt der einer
20-Jährigen mit einem Holzstock so lange
auf den Kopf bis sie wehrlos ist er
nimmt ihr das Fahrrad ab und fährt damit
von Ottbergen nach Hannover mehr als 100
km mit gerade mal 17 kommt er zum ersten
Mal in uhaft und wird schließlich wegen
Diebstahl und schweren Raubes verurteilt
er hatte eine 20-jährige Büroangestellte
Überfall
berbt auch eine 50jährige überfiel zur
we und forderte Geld nach seiner Flucht
aus einer Jugendstrafanstalt versteckt
er sich monatelang in Erdhöhlen
Gartenlauben und
Ferienhäusern später bewirbt er sich im
französischen Metz bei der fremdenleion
wird aber abgelehnt und mit Blick auf
all die Delikte und Strafen in seinen
Akten muss man sagen er hat es nie so
wirklich auf Art gerade Bahn geschafft
1965 bedroht vergewaltigt ze in
Niederbachem bei badgodesberg eine
Freundin mit einem Fleischermesser weil
sie ihn zuvor abgewiesen hatte seinen
Tiefpunkt erreich er aber
1972 im November dieses Jahres tötet
zurweme bei einem Raubüberfall auf ein
Immobilienbüro im
nordreheinwestfähischen Düren eine
Mitarbeiterin durch Stiche in den Hals
Marlon g von der aer Zeitung hat diesen
Tag später sehr gut protokolliert an dem
Tag an dem er seinen Mord beehen sollte
stellt die zurweme morgens fest dass er
dringend Geld braucht er setzt sich in
Würselen auf sein Mofa fährt zum bungalo
seines früheren Chefs klingelt und da
die Frau seines Chefs ihn kennt lässt
sie ihn ins Haus noch während er sie mit
einem Messer bedroht klingelt es erneut
zeme flieht ohne Beute und fährt mit
seinem Mofa zum wirteltorplatz in Düren
in dem Büro des Immobilienmaklers war er
schon zwei Tage vorher gewesen und weiß
daher dass dessen Mitarbeiterin
übermittag alleine im Büro ist erst
macht er mit ihr smalltag und geht dann
wieder später kehrt er zurück bedroht
sie mit dem Messer und fordert Geld er
nimmt ihr Portemonnaie und weil sie so
schreit ersticht er sie bevor zurweme
Ende Januar 1973 in der effel verhaftet
werden kann vergewaltigt er im achner
Raum noch eine Frau und ein 15-jähriges
Mädchen bei einer Gerichtsverhandlung
1974 wird zweme zu einer lebenslangen
Haft verurteilt und tatsächlich scheint
der ewige Schurke zoweme kapiert zu
haben dass es so nicht weitergeht er
wird eine Art Musterschüler unter den
Häftlingen er erledigt nicht nur
Routineaufgaben im Vollzug sehr
ordentlich nee er lernt auch Französisch
und Latein er fängt an Sport zu machen
und nach und nach werden seine Auflagen
gelockert dabei ist seine emintliche
Besserung wohl nichts weiter als schöner
Schein denn später berichten
Mithäftlinge dass zweme von einem auf
den anderen Moment aggressiv wird Frauen
soll er als bezeichnet haben
davon weiß die Justiz aber nichts ab
1988 bekommt er regelmäßig Hafturlaub
wer bei diesem Wort an unseren
dauerausbrecher Frank Schmökel aus der
Folge der untherapierbare denken muss
der hat leider nicht ganz unrecht zwar
besteht das Landgericht klwe
1993 dass die Haft wegen besonderer
Schwere der Schuld
fortdauert aber
1995 kommt zurweme in den offenen
Vollzug bald darf er jobben mal in einer
Wurstfabrik mal als Hilfskoch aber seine
verbalen Ausfälle fallen auch
Therapeuten auf weshalb die Freigänge
zwischendurch sogar gestoppt werden
überhaupt hält zweme in diesem Jahr die
Justiz durch ständige Anträge auf
Haftentlassung auf Trab oder wenn es
darum geht ob er vielleicht doch zu
aggressiv für Freigänge ist dabei tickt
der Mann offenbar die ganze Zeit wie
eine Zeitbombe und die Katastrophe
beginnt am 2 dezember
1998 Dieter zurweme kehrt von seinem 166
Freigang nicht zurück in die Haftanstalt
bielefeldsende er hat offenbar schon
lange an die Flucht gedacht und was
leider auch zu den behördenfehlern
dieser Zeit gehört dass diet zu bei
seinen früheren freigängen einen
Reisepass beantragen konnte und ihn
sogar bekam absurd er flieht in die
Niederlande und bricht auf
Campingplätzen in Wohnwagen ein um darin
zu schlafen und um Essen und
wirdgegenstände an sich zu nehmen auf
diese Weise schlägt sich der
Schwerverbrecher bis zum Frühjahr 1999
durch dann klaut er ein Fahrrad und
macht sich auf den Weg Richtung
Deutschland zurw radelt den reih entlang
überüs D Köln und Bonn bis nach
rehemagen wir haben jetzt das Wochenende
von Freitag dem 19 märz
1999 bis Sonntag den 21 März aufs ganze
Land bezogen keine richtig aufregende
Zeit der Bundestag hat gerade die
Ökosteuer beschlossen nach dem
Jugoslawienkrieg wird noch immer um eine
Friedenslösung gerungen die
Verhandlungen wurden gerade vertagt im
Bankenwesen wird gestreikt die
Gewerkschaften fördern 6,5% mehr L und
Gehalt aber in der Villa in rehmagen
geht es am nächsten Morgen um Leben und
Tod an diesem Samstag Vormittag kommt
der Eigentümer der Villa um nach dem
Rechten auf der Baustelle zu sehen es
handelt sich um den 71-Jährigen Kurt
Schröder er entdeckt zweme stellt ihn
zur Rede und droht mit der Polizei
kurzer Hand zückt zweme ein Messer und
ersticht den Rentner er durchsucht den
Toten und nimmt sich das Portemonnaie
dann klingelt Schröders Handy zu geht
dran und hat Schröders Frau Maria am
Apparat er sagt ihr etwas Schlimmes sei
passiert er werde persönlich
vorbeikommen und es ihr erklären und sie
gibt ihm tatsächlich die Adresse und
wartet zuwem radelt also in Rehagen zur
60jährigen Frau des Mannes den er eben
erstochen hat weil er dort noch mehr
Geld vermutet die Frau lässt ihn rein
zur wee trifft dort aber auch Marias
Bruder Paul bcker 66 und dessen
59jährige Frau Rita und wieder geht
alles ganz schnell Maria und die Bäckers
drohen mit der Polizei und zurweme Stich
zu Maria Schröder und ihr Bruder Paul
sind sofort tot Rita bcker bleibt
blutend liegen er liegt aber später den
Verletzungen in der Wohnung findet zweme
weitere 8000 Mark er nimmt sich bckers
Autoschlüssel und fährt mit dem Wagen
zum Bahnhof und lässt ihn dort stehen
dem entflohenen Freigänger ist ein
vierfachmörder geworden die Polizei
identifiziert ihn durch Fingerabdrücke
in der Villa von nun an sind ztausende
Polizisten in Deutschland angehalten
nach Dieter zurweme zu sehen Zeit ihn
mal zu beschreiben zum Zeitpunkt seiner
Flucht ist Dieter zurweme 56 Jahre alt
der Mann ist schlank und braun gebrannt
das graue Haar auf der Halbglatze trägt
er stoppelkurz zorweme hat einen üppig
grauen Schnurbart er hat schmale Augen
die zusammen mit den markanten
Augenbrauen streng und eindringlich
wirken auf manche wirkt er durchaus
attraktiv das soll am Ende noch eine
Rolle spielen zurwe hält die Polizei
wochenlang zum Narren seine Flucht führt
ihn von Bochum rehemagen Lindau Dessau
Rostock Greifswald frankfurtarmain Kalf
badenbaden Freiburg im Breisgau bis nach
kuckshafen später wird er im Großraum
Hannover gesehen in der gleichnamigen
Region und dem Kreis Schaumburg Lippe
dieses Katz und Mausspiel dauert
Tage
Werbung morgens schon wissen was heute
wichtig wird macht ihr mit dem Bild news
update egal ob News Wirtschaft Politik
Show Sport oder Promis damit bleibt ihr
immer auf dem Laufenden fünf Mal täglich
neu auf Spotify Apple Podcasts Amazon
Google und überall dort wo es Podcast
gibt Werbung
Ende aber als die gestohlenen 8000 Mark
aufgebraucht sind begeht der notorische
Verbrecher wieder Überfälle um sich über
Wasser zu halten und am 21 Juli
1999 vergewaltigt er ein 15jähriges
Mädchen und besonders tragisch ist in
dieser Zeit ein Kapitel das den Namen
Friedhelm Beate trägt
am 27 juni 1999 wird in der Sendung
kpoive eine verandung nach diet zowema
ausgestrahlt auf den Abbildungen trägt
der gesuchte Wanderstock und Rucksack
eine Kellnerin in Thüringen meldet sich
und sagt der Mann sei Gast in dem Hotel
in dem sie arbeite er heiße friedhel
Beate und sei gerade in seinem Zimmer
also Rücken sofort Beamte aus allerdings
fahren Sie los ohne ein Foto von Dieter
z
men Polizisten in Zivil machen sich an
der Hotelzimmertür des Mannes zu
schaffen der denkt wohl er werde
überfallen und drückt dagegen daraufhin
geben die Beamten zwei Schüsse ab und
töten dabei eben nicht wie angenommen
Dieter zorweme sondern Friedhelm Beate
einen im Gebiet geschätzten Wanderer und
Radfahrer wirklich groteske Szenen gibt
es auch als zurwme im Kreis Schaumburg
in einem Maisfeld steckt ein Jäger hatte
ih in der Umgebung gesehen und die
Polizei gerufen die lässt sich aber Zeit
und kommt erst am nächsten Tag mit einem
groß auffgebot soeme ist er natürlich
längst wieder weg mal untersucht die
Polizei liegenelassene Bockwürstchen und
pornoheefte mal nimmt sie irtümlich
männerfest die wie zurweme aussehen das
passiert z.B in fulder und in Dresden
aber erst am 19 August 1999 nehmen zwei
Polizisten Dieter zurweme in Greifswald
fest ein Autofahrer fährt dort viermal
an einem Fußgänger vorbei der aussieht
wie der Mann auf den
verhandlungsplakaten dann als er sich
sicher ist ruft er die 110 als
Polizeibeamte dann eine sogenannte
Personenüberprüfung bei dem Mann
vornehmen sagt der ich bin der den ihr
sucht vier Leute hat zweme in dieser
Zeit 19999 ermordet ein Mädchen
vergewaltigt und die Polizei hat
irtümlich einen völlig unbeteiligten
Wanderer erschossen und das alles weil
ein Mann Freigang hatte der besser
hinter Gittern geblieben wäre und genau
darüber wird jetzt öffentlich gestritten
ein psychiatrischer Gutachter will die
Justiz schon dre Jahre zuvor also
1996 vor zu viel Lockerheit im Umgang
mit Dieter zorweme gewarnt haben der
habe ihn während der Therapie in
Bielefeld gewarnt wenn ich draußen
jemals wieder in die Enge getrieben
werde vergewaltige ich eine Frau aber
niemand habe auf ihn den Therapeuten
gehört 2000 wird dieer zurwehme in
kobelenz der Prozess gemacht wegen
vierfachen Mordes schweren Raubes
Vergewaltigung Nötigung und
Freiheitsberaubung verurteilt das
Landgericht ihn zu lebenslanger
Freiheitsstrafe und Sicherungsverwahrung
er ist in der JVA Bochum inhaftiert und
hier kommt ein letzter wirklich
verstörender Teil der Geschichte noch
während des Prozesses bekommt zurweme
unzählige Liebesbriefe in den Knast
darunter 15 Heiratsanträge das ist das
klingt vielleicht schräg aber das das
hört man ja immer mal wieder also
zuletzt auch z.B in der sehr sehr
bekannten Doku Jeffrey D der auch
Menschen umgebracht und sogar gegessen
hat und selbst er hat fenpost ins
Gefängnis bekommen aus den
Heiratsanträgen sucht sich der
Mehrfachmörder eine Frau aus Berlin
Spandau aus laut dem pensionierten
Kommissar starke sagt zurweme die Kuh
solle noch 20 abnehmen dann würde er sie
heiraten und tatsächlich geben sich
beide am 15 Februar 2001 in der JV
Bochum das jahwort sie sagt damals zu
Bild es gebe ein zwem auch wirklich gute
Seiten die nur keiner kenne einige Jahre
später stirbt die Frau zoweme lebt jetzt
als widwer im Knast ja hoffentlich bis
ans Lebensende und trotz all dieser
Fehler die passiert sind die absolut
lich sind da brauchen wir gar nicht
drüber diskutieren finde ich dass unser
Rechtssystem richtig ist und ich finde
das gut dass hier jeder eine zweite
Chance verdient hat ja stimmt da die
Mehrheit der straffällig gewordenen
Personen dankbar ist für diese Chance
auf Wiedereingliederung in die
Gesellschaft nur wenn bei der
Einschätzung der Risikobeurteilung
Fehler gemacht werden t dann können
diese Fehler durchaus tödliche Folgen
haben ja und ich glaube das ist ja
ähnlich wie beim Fall Schmökel oder der
Rosar Riese das ist so ein Impuls zu
sagen was für unglaubliche Fehler wie
konnte das nur passieren also man haut
da so direkt volle Pulle drauf
allerdings sollten wir nicht vergessen
jeder macht Fehler das ist auch nicht
vermeidbar allerdings haben halt Fehler
im Umgang mit z.B Mördern oder
Vergewaltigern ein ganz anderes Ausmaß
die können potenziell unschuldigendes
Leben kosten oder
wenn sie es überleben das Leben
zerstören deshalb ist diese
Risikobeurteilung enorm wichtig ein
Garant ist die aber nie und was in
diesem Fall richtig gewaltig schief
gelaufen ist ist dass der Psychologe
gewarnt hat aber nicht darauf gehört
wurde und Z weme so diesen Ausgang
bekommen hat sehr guter Hinweis Tony und
damit sind wir am Ende unserer heutigen
Episode angelangt wir danken euch dass
ihr wieder mit dabei wart eure Tony und
euer Mirko diesen Fall haben wir
vorbereitet mit dem Archiv von Axel
Springer sowie Artikeln aus der aender
Zeitung der reheinischenpost und den
Schaumburger Nachrichten Aufnahme und
schnitt Tony haer Skript Stefan
Netzeband Postproduktion wakew Studios
München dir hat diese Folge von Tatort
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
True Crime einfach nicht genug dann hör
jetzt in unsere weiteren Folgen rein
hier warten mehr als 200 spannende fäler
auf dich wie das Verschwinden von
Rebecca Rusch der Prozess gegen OJ
Simpson oder die Entführung von ursela
Herrmann wir hören uns bei Tat
Deutschland